[Musique]
mais là les époques les dangers quand
d'aventuré zapper
et encore elle quoi comment ça j'ai pas
le scénario en avance enfin c'est quoi
ces conditions de travail auditeurs on
dirait que je vais l'avoir d'écrire
l'histoire en même temps que vous tous
barre en couille
vous vous rappelez de iris elliott et
thomas un lapin mystérieux annonce eiris
qu'elle va avoir un enfant avec thomas
et les fait voyager dans le temps
destination j'en sais rien je vous
rappelle je te faire grève
bienvenue la destination on est de
retour chez moi où on est dans le futur
os c'est trop cool c'est vraiment comme
dans ma chambre en fait c'est sombre et
bordélique c'est le laboratoire du
docteur sin n'hésitait pas à mettre 5
étoiles il trajet vous a plus sur
l'application rabhi poids je reviens pas
je suis donc fait une course offerte si
vous parrainez un ami iris inapte à
gober 28 vous êtes là je suis si
contente entendre votre voix nous on
s'est dit et à 5 minutes mais ça fait
plus d'un an pour moi écoutez il ya une
catastrophe à oui je sais thomas et moi
allons avoir un enfant dans le futur
quoi comment on peut éviter ça quel est
le rapport
et comment vous le savez ça c'est moi
qui leur ai dit pour m'avoir envoyé les
chercher comme j'ai déjà rencontré dans
le futur si hank la fia n'a aucun
rapport avec d'autres problèmes de toute
façon le futur n'existe plein kwakwa
iris il se passe quelque chose de
terrible le monde va s'effondrer
il est déjà effondré pour moi elliot on
va dans le futur pour découvrir mon
enfant très bien allons-y cheminots même
si les bourses et les couteaux - faut
mieux
on ne peut plus aller dans le futur
quelqu'un a cassé le temps papa a raison
ma machine ne détecte plus de futurs ni
de passer non exactement quoi les
machines ne fonctionnent plus mais c'est
pire que ça quelqu'un cassait les règles
vous vous souvenez quand je vous
expliquais qu'on ne peut rien changer
dans le passé et bah c'est fini
maintenant le moindre changement dans le
passé modifie directement notre présent
c'est une catastrophe on a trop bien au
laser du futur le proto ma ça sert juste
à faire une petite lumière rouge pour
pointer des présentations de sawa laser
qui tue je sers la menace est terrible
regardez cette allocution de notre
président de la république d l'emotion
toi comme j'adore sa clique de nos jours
au début les présidents en votant sur
internet
il a gagné face à nick serff cette
menace très au sérieux car c'est mon
devoir de protéger le port
de la vérité virtuel a disparu même sort
pour notre secrétaire d'état a dit ce
porte
nous ferons tout pour protéger les
c
ce décret ça s'est passé il ya une heure
impossible de décrypter son visage ou
savent l'utiliser dailymotion dans le
futur il faut faire quelque chose
absolument et cette personne a déjà
commencé à modifier le passé j'ai réussi
à détecter une activité temporal étrange
le malfaiteur encore assassiner
quelqu'un mais dans le passé
qui ça aucune idée en revanche j'ai
réussi à noter sein avant que le présent
soit modifié ce serait l'inventeur du
mot jouarre le quoi j'ai noté ce un
mouchoir
ça doit être un truc pour attraper les
mouches toujours est il qu'avant ça
existait maintenant ça n'existe pas
tomates et dégueulasse la table à
marthon ouais mais je sais pas quoi mais
sujet mois va jouer ailleurs on parle
d'un truc important là mais surtout ne
touche à rien ok ok pas comment traite
assassin fait pour voyager dans le temps
c'est trop cool comme laborde
c'est quoi ça une virée une machine avez
une petite photo
ça fait quoi sait jamais ce gros boutons
un danseur et photoshop une fenêtre je
vois pas ressembler futur ouais ouais
c'est pas du tout comme j'imaginais
pourquoi ils ont mis tous ces machins
des trucs qui pendent aux copeaux à un
ordinateur
je me ferais bien une petite partie de
fortes malte où coule c'est ça il va
faire ton pas dans le futur alors entré
prénom global dow ma nom de famille
voilà processus en cours quand ça procès
suit son cours mais moi je veux jouer
mais c'est quoi ce temps d
oh
où suis-je kelly cette odeur nauséabonde
ray c'est quoi ça ah bonjour petit
bonhomme chétif nous sommes pas qu'est
ce que j'ai fait deux tête me dit
quelque chose je me présente je
m'appelle thomas aw est pas comme moi
enchanté désolé petit thomas je ne
contrôle pas ma force je n'ai aucune
idée dont on retrouve mais je t'aime
mais on est dans le futur tu viens d'où
toi mon monde ressemblait à celui ci
mais un jour tout a changé
il ya un grand fracas et la vie est
devenue infernale j'ai vécu des
souffrances qu'aucun humain ne peut
imaginer
j'ai passé mon temps à sauver les
victimes de ce monde devenu fou
et puis tout d'un coup je me retrouve
devant toi et toi d'où viens-tu gamin
chalon sur saône pas mais moi aussi ça
me rappelle le temps je me faisais
racketter au collège robert benoit aussi
je me faisais racketter au collège
robert doisneau meilleur français
j'avais ma dame des champs bat sommes
déjà ma mère elle est assistante de
direction dans un gros de réparation et
de remplacement par brise carglass
répare carglass remplace et attends
attends pas tant tout se met en place
dans ma tête
si on a le même prénom la même scolarité
la même marque de tabac et oui ah non
merci
témoin du futur rebond c'est génial dans
le futur
[Musique]
et c'est qui lui
bonjour à tous je m'appelle thomas vous
présente mon mois du futur du futur la
balance toi tu featurettes où il sort
j'ai dû taper mon nom dans l'ordinateur
lama et mon mois du futur des futures
est arrivé en il ne fallait surtout pas
utiliser sa chérie thomas va devenir
aussi musclé c'est vrai que le
changement est dur à croire mais ils ont
clairement avait rejeté un contrôle
parental sur cette horde ça pourrait
peut-être expliquer pourquoi
excusez moi dans le futur on a un enfant
ensemble
désolé mademoiselle mais je n'ai aucun
souvenir de vous avoir croisé il faut
dire que mon esprit n'est plus très
fiable
j'ai vécu un enfer pendant d éternité en
époque il n'y a pas le temps de fonder
une famille car le monde est tout
simplement invivable
le danger permanente c'est l'apocalypse
et de quelle année viens tu quand je
regarde ton cornes musclé tapo plein des
cicatrices et à barbe de trois jours
viril mais relax j'ai du mal à croire
que tu as été le thomas du passé c'est
vrai regardez là vous préférez pas
l'appeler thomas du futur et moi vous
m'appelez thomas comme d'habitude qui
doit tomber du pc thomas tu peux nous
aider si je peux aider
c'est avec un grand plaisir que faut-il
faire alors quelqu'un essaie de modifier
le temps je pense que supprimer
l'invention du mouchoir était juste un
coup d'essai il faut absolument garder
les événements connaissons car plus
l'histoire change plus notre présent va
être modifié et ces changements nous
mèneront directement à notre disparition
aurait pas 4 même à une faille
temporelle d'esprit c'est une
catastrophe
inquiétez pas on va s'en sortir ou d'un
laser jamais c'est un laser qui le
tomber quoi
mais tata indique une nouvelle activité
suspecte en 1912 dans le seau atlantique
très bien à lausitz breton moralisation
dans
nos machines ne fonctionnent plus
j'avais oublié mais il reste moyen celui
par lequel je vous ai fait venir c'est
moi lapin est le résultat d'une
expérience qui a mal tourné toutes tes
expériences tourne mal parties civiles
qua non je le disais que tu es un ami
quelle chance de t'avoir rencontré tu me
dis parfois la même chose d'acquis cela
pas développer une intelligence hors
norme et absorber la capacité du voyage
dans le temps il est le seul à voyager
dans le temps donc tout sommes les seuls
à pouvoir sauver le monde
très bien voilà le plan le petit lapin
nous emmène sur les traces du fils de
qui veut modifier le temps et on le
met hors d'état nul elliott thomas
allait devoir nous appelle son volume ou
l'histoire je reste ici c'est pour vous
envoyer des indications tenez ça ce sont
des taux n'est que je viens de
confectionner elles sont trempés morts
elle s'adapte à l'époque que vous
visitez ça vous aidera être le plus
discret possible
vous êtes sûr qu'on rentre dedans c'est
vrai que c'est mou lent mais c'est
confortable bois touffus risque il fait
soudan fait plus c'est la première fois
que jamais active et mortelle a eu marre
et vêtements possède une puce qui
traduira toutes les langues autour de
vous quoi je ne peux plus voyager dans
le temps et mon traducteur universel ne
vous sert plus à rien je me semble que
nous tirons mel young déprime pas comme
ça thomas tu passes et non plus sert à
rien ça n'empêche pas de vivre des
aventures avec nous grave vu que tu peux
nous faire encore du café du café génial
le café a disparu de mon monde
je peux avoir un café bien serré de
puissants avec plaisir de café très
serré et impuissant pourtant ma tu veux
dire que ma des futures c'est relou que
tu va la faire à chaque fois thomas du
passé ah bon je me sens utile à nouveau
merci beau le monde conditions sont
inquiètes papa on va assurer petit lapin
en mai nous assez coordonnés direction
l'océan atlantique 1912
n'hésitez pas à me demander si vous
voulez une bouteille d'eau ou des
bonbons à la menthe de temporisation
dans ce cas là c'est quoi son envol
[Applaudissements]
suivant m on a une chance sur combien
d'arriver sur un bateau on est sur notre
kit annick thomas dit pas c'est qu'un
bateau magnifique
voilà arrivés à destination depuis chez
vous car le temps est en train d'être
modifiée
je le sens dans les voiles regardez nos
avec moi elle est trop belle trop vieux
je porte une salopette bleue c'est un
vêtement il m'a très pratique sauf pour
aller aux toilettes
et comme je ne vais pas aux toilettes
c'est le vêtement parfait thomas est pas
mal dans son petit costard de serveurs
et pourquoi mes vêtements sont sales et
déchirés ou non mais attendez et si on
est sur le titanic
ça veut dire qu'on va couler iris a
raison le titanic et en bas tout connu
pour avoir coulé et quel film mes amis
qui est cette menace qui veut détruire
le temps comment thomas a pu devenir
aussi différent dans le futur
que devient le futur dirige va-t-elle
avoir un enfant pourquoi on me donne
plus les scénarios en avance enfin je
vais devoir suivre les aventures comme
les audits arms pilon
merci d'avoir écouté le premier épisode
de la nouvelle saison de l'épopée
temporel et à la semaine prochaine pour
la suite